this is a salon of oh hey the Kings
Ellie's private room in his own museum
he used it when doing interviews and
meeting friends
Claudia on the staff here is showing us
around a photo of him with his parents
the chair he sat in
[Music]
ordinary objects made somehow important
by the presence of one enormously famous
she got to know him during her time
working here
very kind always treated everyone as if
it was a pleasure to see them he was a
special person Pele was more than a
person he was a brand important enough
for the Brazilian government to build
this Museum
all of the foreigners used to visit the
museum because he the King was so
important he was an idol a myth now he's
become immortal
but he was only two mortal vulnerable to
begin with
it's quite poignant actually that the
museum starts with the shoe box that
pelay built with his uncle and he was
shining shoes at a very young age at the
local railway station this is where it
all started for him the sort of poverty
I suppose that his family was in
that boy became the man of a thousand
goals who could shoot with both feet run
the 100 meters in 11 seconds hover
seemingly supernaturally in the air
everyone wanted a photo with him and
they still do
that
I traveled a thousand kilometers to take
a picture with the king I mean he was a
really good player but what makes him so
special that he was worth driving a
thousand kilometers for oh my God who
has three stars he says referring to
pele's three World Cup wins he's still
the only one
from there to the Pinnacle of celebrity
meetings with monarchs presidents movie
stars endless endorsement deals
the little boy who grown up shining
shoes in Brazil had gone Global and he
stayed there till his death
but it didn't dim the affection for him
back home in the night air of Santos the
town whose team he played for where his
museum is
a thousand voices sang the Santa's
Anthem in homage in the last moments of
a Dying year
hello departed with it but an enormous
affection remains for him here
John Holman Al Jazeera Santos